G
REPUBLICAN, BUT THEY THINK THAT
THAT IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
BRAINWASHED WITH DISINFORMATION.
THERE'S PROBABLY NO COUNTY MORE
SYMBOLICALLY IMPORTANT THAN
MIAMI-DADE COUNTY.
SOUTH FLORIDA.
NEW POLLING THERE INDICATES THAT
RON DESANTIS MAY WIN MIAMI-DADE
COUNTY.
SO HOW DID RON APPARENTLY SHIFT
MIAMI-DADE REPUBLICANS?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE EXACTLY?
AND ACTUALLY RON DESANTIS JOINS
US TONIGHT.
GOVERNOR?
>> HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
IT DOES SEEM POSSIBLE THAT YOU
WILL WIN MIAMI-DADE COUNTY,
WHICH WOULD NOT HAVE SEEMED
POSSIBLE TWO YEARS AGO.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON AND
WHY?
>> I THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FACTORS, FIRST, I WAS THE
GOVERNOR THAT WAS SAVING THEIR
JOBS, THEIR BUSINESSES, KEEPING
THEIR KIDS IN SCHOOL DURING
COVID-19.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OPPOSED ME
ON EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
POLICIES, THEY WANTED BASICALLY
INDEFINITE LOCK DOWNS, SCHOOL
CLOSURES, THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR
BLUE-COLLAR PEOPLE.
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN VERY STRONG ON
CRIME.
I IMMEDIATELY CALLED OUT THE
NATIONAL GUARD, WE WERE NOT
GOING TO LET THAT HAPPEN IN
FLORIDA.
WE ARE A LAW AND ORDER STATE, I
THINK THAT THAT IS IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THAT WE REFLECT
VALUES RAISING KIDS.
INCLUDING MAKING SURE THAT THE
KIDS WOULD NOT BE SEXUALIZED IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, THAT COULD BE
THINGS LIKE GENDER IDEOLOGY
BEING OUT OF THE CLASSROOM, BUT
IT'S LEFT THAT WANTS TO PUT IT
IN THERE.
SO I THINK YOU SEE LATINOS,
BLUE-COLLAR PEOPLE SAYING HEY,
WE ARE REPRESENTING THEM.
WE ARE STANDING UP FOR THEM,
THEIR JOBS, THEIR EDUCATION AND
SAFETY AS WELL AS THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> I ONCE SAW A FAMOUS
REPUBLICAN TELL MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS THAT THEY WANTED TO WIN
AND IF THEY WANTED TO THEY HAD
TO MOVE LEFT AND YOU ARE SAYING
THAT THEY HAVE TO MOVE TO THE
RIGHT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
INCLUDING ON IMMIGRATION.
CENTURY CITY'S, THEY THOUGHT IT
WOULD NOT BE APPROVED DOWN HERE,
AND YET HISPANIC VOTERS IN
FLORIDA HAVE THE HIGHEST
APPROVAL RATING FOR OUR POLICY
TO BAN SANCTUARY CITIES.
WE DID THE TRANSPORTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, PEOPLE
THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
BE SO BAD, AND YET THE VOTERS
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BORDER IS
OUT OF CONTROL.
SO I THINK IT'S ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES, BUT CLEARLY THE
REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT WITH
OPEN BORDERS, AMNESTY, TO APPEAL
WITH HISPANIC VOTERS IN THE
UNITED STATES, IT WAS WRONG
THEN, IT'S CLEARLY BEEN PROVEN
TO BE WRONG NOW.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING IT FOR
30 YEARS.
AN AMAZING EXPERIMENT